welcome back to Startalk we are
featuring my interview with actress
Mayim Bialik she is the neuroscientist
on the hit TV series The Big Bang Theory
and I asked her about the portrayal of
women's scientist is it good is it bad
is it working let's check it out
we did an episode where Bernadette poses
for a sexy scientist um photoshoot and
Amy has a very big problem I remember
that I'm sure it's something that I'm
asked about a lot cuz I do advocacy for
stem and young women and I'm often asked
you know what do you think about the you
know the white starched shirt open with
the black bra and the glasses down on
the red lips and you know and to me III
don't knock women or scientists who want
to do that for me that's not the way
that I choose to portray women in
science you know I don't think we need
to take our clothes off you know to show
that women and science can also take
their clothes off but I think you know
part of the advocacy that I try and do
is to put a fresh face you know a
positive face and a female face on these
subjects I think that a lot of also
what's missing from trying to engage
young women is not just the sex factor
or the attractiveness factor which I do
agree might be more important in in this
day and age then it might have been ten
or twenty or fifty years ago but I think
also that a lot of women don't know the
kinds of careers that are available to
them and people picture themselves or at
least I did I don't want to be alone in
a lab for the rest of my life I don't
want to be in a nerdy lab coat and ugly
glasses for the rest of my and that's
what when I was in elementary school and
junior high that's what I thought it was
but when I got older and I understood Oh
marine biology is actually being a
scientist working in the field working
with animals working in the environment
you know all those things are also
science if you like engineering and you
want to do coding knock yourself out but
there are many careers that involve a
lot of creativity and a lot of being out
and about and that's I think what we
need to try and communicate to girls as
young as possible